so what does it really take to go full
time on youtube you know after growing a
couple different channels to over 100
000 subscribers getting three silver
play buttons
our main channel think media to over a
million getting that gold play button
and interviewing hundreds of
entrepreneurs and creators
i've noticed some trends and some
pitfalls
uh when it comes to going full-time on
youtube i've noticed some things that
those that really succeed over the long
haul have
and i've noticed those that have gotten
stuck or have actually
stopped growing mistakes and traps
they've fallen into and so i'm really
excited because in this video i'm going
to be breaking down our brand new
youtube domination framework
which will help you get more clarity on
your journey to going full time
maybe you're kind of unsure about your
next step or where you are on the
journey and what to expect next
i believe you're going to get a lot of
value out of this video and
some recent data has actually been
revealed that
youtube's greater economy is bigger and
more profitable than ever before so
there really has been
never a better time this next decade is
going to be the best decade on youtube
and it revealed that 2 million creators
have joined youtube's partner program
and they get a share of the site's
revenue i'm sure you know how the
program works
which totaled 46 billion dollars over
the past
three years what's crazy is 30 million
30 billion with a b has been paid to
creators
in the last three years of that money
so that's just one way to make money the
youtube partner program
and this article from fortune is talking
about these trends happening in the
creator economy
that are just absolutely massive it also
says that the growing creator economy
has helped not just
the superstars with the largest
audiences but has also enabled
a middle class of creators
so what's exciting about that it goes
deeper in the article and we'll link to
it in the description below that
um the middle class of youtube creators
is not just making their money off
adsense but they figured out multiple
different ways to earn money they've
really created a business and i don't
know
let me know in the comments do you think
of your youtube channel as a business or
is more of a hobby
because those that are really going full
time and that's our mission here at
think media to help 10
000 purpose-driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with youtube they
are carving out this path that it's more
practical than ever you may have seen
the signal fire stats this is the
fastest growing small business type
so today though i want to talk about the
youtube domination framework and how to
create
consistent success on youtube smash like
if you're fired up
and i'm going to be talking about the
lessons i've learned after getting 150
million
video views uh building a multi-million
dollar business but also
literally now interviewing hundreds of
hobby creators that turned pro and
really built a business around their
creativity their art their comedy their
entertainment
also business owners who started a
youtube channel to generate more sales
more leads
and those that are kind of just stepping
into the crater economy
finding their path finding their way to
earning a full-time and part-time living
on youtube
i'm also going to talk about why your
approach to youtube could actually be a
path to anxiety and burnout
it could and i've been thinking about
this more than ever before and the three
places
that youtube creators get stuck if we're
just meeting my name sean cannell
and uh i my passion is helping you grow
your channel with youtube i'm most
excited about our students
uh the think media team and i have
helped thousands of people create a
part-time
and full-time income from youtube a lot
of people get that silver play button
build that business so if you haven't
subscribed yet smash subscribe
but one of the reasons why i've been
thinking about this sustainable path to
youtube success is i'm a new dad
i've got an eight month old named sean
bradley you can see he got into the
kleenex
my joby gorillapod uh my film clapper
you know i put him behind me here in the
office while i'm recording this
and he's he's the chaos candidate we
call him the dictator like he's just
he's awesome he's amazing but he's he's
he a lot of times pulls those books off
the shelf behind him
and that's my wife sonia and of course
you know shout out to the parents
if you let me know if you can relate
when you maybe enter parenthood or maybe
a pivotal time in your life where you
faced a challenge maybe a health
challenge a financial challenge
maybe an existential crisis of going
through 2020 and being like
can we go outside again what's this
what's happening what am i going to do
with my life
what have i done up into this point you
had a lot of time to think a lot of time
to worry maybe or whatever
as a parent now i'm asking questions
like is this sustainable
like what i'm doing on youtube what kind
of example am i being for my son
what am i building and what am i doing
for the next generation
so this youtube domination framework was
really inspired
out of seeing so many good things in the
creator economy but also seeing some
dangerous traps that are leading to
anxiety and burnout
and so let's get into it so this is the
youtube domination framework if you ever
seen one of these before
you can see that it's it starts at zero
and you can have you could rate yourself
on a scale from one to ten
on the x-axis right and one to ten on
the y-axis
and the first axis is views when it
comes to winning on youtube
you know it's all about how many can i
get the views
and a lot of us can focus just on this
let me know how you're doing
scale from one to ten how do you feel
like your views are going tell me in the
comments
so you know how many views can i get
this is kind of predominantly the main
question on youtube
how do i get more views where can i get
more views on every social media
platform i want to i want to get more
views i want to get more views you know
what i mean and that also could be like
likes it's like kind of the metrics they
might be vanity metrics they might be
real metrics i mean views
is impact for sure no question right but
sometimes
and i see this all the time people are
getting a lot of views but they haven't
really figured out how to make
the money the money side of things so
then you could rate yourself on a scale
from
zero to ten how am i doing with the
money
and those who understand how to build a
business or maybe come into youtube with
the pre-existing business
maybe that you're in network marketing
you already have a business model
you may imagine now only need to be like
a two on views but if you're a 10 on
money you're doing all right
if you were like a 5 on views and a five
on money
like you're you're right in here like
you could be doing pretty good
but what uh the ultimate goal of course
would be to master
how do i get traffic how do i get views
and also master
the ways of making money on youtube what
business model am i going to do have i
created multiple income streams
have i figured out how to scale my
income have i also figured out how to
recession proof my income
in case one thing dries up advertisers
if i'm dependent on brand deals what if
brand deals dry up
and so really what we start off with
here
uh the first kind of person or
the first step in all of our journeys is
we're going to start out as the dabbler
and let me know what journey you kind of
fall into i'll give you a couple other
ones
but the dabbler and this makes sense
right if you're on the dabbler stage
you just aren't taking youtube serious
yet right that's okay
and maybe it's more of a hobby you
haven't stepped into
like i'm a dabbler in the gym in fact i
don't even go to the gym
i have exercise bands and i got some
kettlebells i haven't been lifting them
so i can't say that i'm serious about
building muscle
because my actions don't back it up
right and so
um you may be a dabbler if you consume
more videos than you create
shots fired but you know like if you're
just watching a lot of youtube but
you're not actually making videos you're
still dabbling
like if you dream more than you do
sometimes we can get stuck we have all
idea we're ideal people oh there's so
many channels i could start well why
don't you start one
well there's so many videos i can make
why don't you actually make one and post
it
right we dream more than we do you maybe
are a dabbler if you're getting
distracted by shiny objects other social
media platforms
you're starting uh you you're starting
other channels or you're thinking about
writing a book and a podcast all at the
same time
in fact you've posted like 10 videos on
your first channel and you're like
should i start two other channels i have
more ideas that is a dabbler move that's
what
because it keeps us stuck if we're
spread too thin we're not going to get
the views
or the money we're stuck in dabbling and
everyone starts at zero
but the problem with being a dabbler is
you have
a genuine desire to succeed on youtube
for sure you want to succeed
but you're ultimately uncommitted listen
i don't mean to call you out but you
could call me out and say sean
you say you want the biceps but you're
not doing the work
you got to commit so the action here is
to decide
i'm gonna just shift from dabbling to
dominating and i'm gonna actually commit
right
so then what happens typically and this
is the trap that the majority fall into
is is the influencer is the influencer
now
congratulations if you make it here
it takes a lot of work it's going to
take some luck some timing
and you have some videos with a lot of
views you've got some subscribers
you know you may be posting a lot of
content on youtube you might have just
started tick tock or instagram
and you're like dude i've got some stuff
that's happening i got some views
the money is coming in and
if you're not very high on the money
scale it might not be coming in but but
if you're a 10
on an influencer in terms of views your
ability to create content that's
triggering the algorithm and like a
three on money you're doing pretty well
however i've met a lot of successful
influencers that are living paycheck to
paycheck
and what happens here is the trap is an
influencers main goal is typically just
to go viral
they haven't built a sustainable
business
that isn't relying on their next viral
video and maybe you've even heard of
like the starving artist
and by the way the starving artist might
have thousands coming in but it's like
frick i'm only as good as my last viral
can i keep this up you know like and the
metrics you measure
is more your subscriber account than
your bank account
now i'm not suggesting that like this
has anything to do with an obsession of
money
when you think like a business owner
cash is oxygen for a business
so the influencer is actually focused
more on image potentially than impact
and is focused just more on getting more
views but is not really the
sustainability like
is this just me the dancing bear riding
the bike or if i start
if i stop riding the bike this whole
thing stops where's my next paycheck
coming from where's my next brand deal
coming from
this is just the trap you can fall into
major respect if you make it to a 10 an
influencer
and then you're also probably exhausted
because you're on the treadmill of
creating content and if you don't stop
running
your content creation business would
stop it's all about you
you're just you're the influencer you're
the personal brand right
and the worry is what happens if my 15
minutes of fame are over
now there's an article on medium uh
magazine
that actually talked about the downside
like this is a real career like this
influencer career this
this crater economy but they said the
down side of being an influencer
is while we only get a glimpse of your
glamorous life
most influencers suffer anxiety
because they fear losing their relevance
man i think we could probably all feel
that by the way i've walked through all
of these steps i've been in these steps
like i just need more views can i get
more views
sometimes the answer is not more views
it's actually more clarity it's more
impact it's dialing in your strategy and
not just trying to go for the vanity
metric
and what what if i'm only as good as my
last video
you feel losing your relevance can you
relate to this is this valuable
uh being irrelevant is as good as losing
your job in the influencer i'm reading
this
uh in the influencer career influencers
can't just copy what someone else is
doing all the time
there's a constant pressure to be
creative with your ideas and to ensure
that you aren't posting offensive
content
and to create something that will
increase your followers
sometimes you you're at you're at the
mercy of pleasing your followers
of of selling your soul to the algorithm
instead of your purpose and your vision
this is just the temptations
right and uh you you get hate comments
and so there's a whole emotional thing
that comes along with it and am i
pleasing
because most influencers way of making
money of course there's a youtube
partner program with ads
but it's brand deals it's gonna be
working for other bosses
you have bosses you've got brands that
are telling you what to do when to post
it what's okay to post
so sometimes it chokes out the
influencers creativity
so ultimately again this is great
congratulations like if you're if you
move from dabbler to influencer
and even start earning a little bit of
money then things could start going
pretty good and let me know if you could
relate to either of those but the next
one's the pusher
okay this next kind of path people find
themselves in is the pusher
notice you're not very good at getting
views potentially you're like a three at
getting views
but maybe you're like a tenant business
model and figuring out how to make money
so the pusher has a business model and
something to sell and is good at making
money
um they've they've built some kind of
sustainable
you're your own business owner when
you're your own business owner you have
your own products and services
of course you can build a business based
on advertising but again that's the up
and down
so the business owners created something
that they control
okay that's that's a good part problem
is though
or usually the way the pusher is wired
is
no matter what you're going to push and
you're going to get it done so sometimes
it feels like a grind to make money the
problem is
you've you haven't figured out how to
consistently get views and you don't
have a wide enough audience so
sometimes you can fall into being the
pushy salesman
because it's a small audience you got
the business model but you got to hammer
it because you're trying to pay the
bills
and the truth is the best way to market
in this new decade
is no pressure nobody wants
the car salesman might still work some
places but like that's
that's dead and gone it's about service
it's about value
it's about patience it's about farming
not hunting you know what i mean nobody
wants to be hunted
you want to be farmed in the sense of
you just want to be cultivated watered
invited to like hey if you want to do
business together like we can if you
don't that's cool too like there's no
push
but when you don't have enough views you
don't have a big enough audience you can
fall into the trap of being the pusher
and you just have to constantly apply
pressure plus you also are trading your
time for money
because chances are you've you don't
have enough audience or momentum reviews
so that every time you want to get paid
you have to push
and you might be frustrated because if
you had the views of the influencer
you'd ultimately have both
pieces so this brings us to
the crossroads out of these three which
one can you relate to the most i'm just
curious
the dabbler the influencer or the pusher
do you feel like the dabbler which is
you're just starting and maybe you will
admit sean i am not fully committed like
i just was just
i don't want to fully commit youtube's
kind of fun i'm doing on the side i
might commit later
but if would you admit that you're
really not committed you're not staying
consistent you're not going to the gym
multiple times a week and eating healthy
you say you want to get in shape but you
you have a lot more big ideas and dreams
than you do have real actions that's the
dabbler
would you admit you're being there do
you actually feel like you're the
influence you're like dude i'm getting
views but i just feel like i don't got
the business model i don't got the
clarity
and i feel like if i don't keep pushing
on this bike if i don't keep riding this
pedalton
i could lose my momentum and i don't
even know if i stop
my business stops i haven't really built
a business
i don't really have assets or ip or
things that i own i just work with
brands
uh do you find yourself somewhere in the
middle you know
or or are you the pusher you're like
yeah i got i got
coaching i got programs i got a course i
got products i got services i got a
consulting i got
physical goods i got some things but man
i just don't got the audience i don't
have the traffic
so i feel like i just got to keep
pushing so i can hit my financial
targets every month
where do you feel like you're at
on your journey daniel says closer to
the uh the pusher uh tamara
joy's saying becoming an influencer but
not thrilled about that i like that's
good self-awareness
like that's why i hope this is helpful
i'm more the pusher
eb3 tech you know lauren says i'm more
a dabbler but i want to move to the
influencer on my way to being the pusher
dabbler thanks for you know being honest
uh and
i'm more of an influencer but i'm going
for the pusher season well
uh keep posting too and it's great to
see you thanks for being here live
uh with uh with me today uh but
ultimately
we don't want to end in any of these
spots no matter where you are today the
good news
is that we all start somewhere and we
all go through different seasons
and you'll probably find yourself
navigating through these seasons
but the important thing so we succeed on
our youtube journey towards going full
time is clarity of where we want to go
what it's going to look like and what
skills we need to learn to get there or
adapt into or grow into
it's kind of like if you've ever heard
if someone flies
if an airplane flies from florida to
seattle across the united states
if the navigation is off by just one or
two degrees
they'll end two hours off course like if
i'm flying to seattle where i grew up my
hometown
i don't want to end in portland oregon
and have to uber for hundreds of dollars
you know to hunt you know to get to
seattle i want to arrive at the right
destination
but if you're just a few degrees off
course in terms of what you're aiming
for
a year from now three years from now you
could find yourself wildly away from
what your original intent was
that's why i hope this information is
massively value for you
valuable for you because again what are
you building
like man i'm trying to be i'm just
trying to get views but what has it got
me or where has it got me a couple years
from now
or i'm just i'm on this treadmill i'm
pushing i'm pushing
and so ultimately over my journey and
especially from interviewing so many
people that have graduated if you will
from these seasons
by intentional choice strategy mentoring
coaching decisions navigation they made
sure they had a compass
they defined where they wanted to go and
they set this as a target
really the goal is to be the youtube
preneur
is to be the youtube preneur okay
so what's that again if you're like
a five at influence views right views
likes
audience and like a five at money that's
that's phenomenal like it's kind of a
good balance
but you know if you thought about like
10 10
like how can i how can i get to that 10
10 level if we
built the dream youtube channel for
going full time it's the youtubepreneur
and so let's define that and we'll talk
a little bit about this and then i have
three powerful questions to help you
kind of clarify your youtube journey for
you
so the youtubepreneur is an individual
who has built
a sustainable profitable
and scalable business
this is one thing you got to wrap your
mind around jay-z said it this way he
said i'm not a businessman
i am a business
man i'm a business okay that's us as
influencers personal brands
but you got to start thinking like a
business and i find that most dope
sometimes the term can even say well
like i'm a creator i'm a creative
like come on dude i'm just entertaining
i'm gaming i'm like i'm you know i
like i'm not a business you gotta think
like a business
because what is a business
right a business is something that is
actually
generating profit a business is
something that is actually
uh i think i wrote the definition down
for this
so that i would be powerfully prepared
for this exact
moment a business is an entity that
seeks to profit from an activity
a business i've heard entrepreneurship
defined this way an entrepreneur solves
problems for a profit
so you make a decision what problem do i
solve and i'm actually and i'm also
profitable
that's like we shouldn't be afraid of
that like people are like we're afraid
of making money
well you can't go full time without
making money you actually can't feed
your kids or build a legacy or build
something sustainable or build
generational wealth if you don't make
money
so you gotta you have to stop
apologizing you're in business
right this is a business and not only
that
but it's sustainable
and the trap of either being in the
influencer or even the pusher side it's
not
necessarily sustainable you're pushing
too hard you haven't you haven't you
don't have both views and money
profitable meaning there's money left
over after you spend your expenses
and scalable meaning it can scale and
grow up now this is a big
by the way i'm painting like this could
be a three four five
six seven eight nine ten year journey it
really could
because sometimes the problem too with a
personal brand is it may not be very
scalable
and the only way to make anything
scalable is eventually to start building
a team
and and other things systems and things
like that
the aspects that real businesses have
guess what businesses have uh teams
systems a business plan a business model
okay you got it let's finish the
definition so a youtuber is an
individual who has built a sustainable
profitable and scalable business on
youtube
that generates consistent views
not seasonal views not views because you
got lucky once
not i went viral do you know how many
viral videos there have been
from people who literally had 15 minutes
of fame and are nowhere to be seen
i'm not trying to dishonor or disrespect
them it happens all the time
dude a viral video is not your answer it
may be your answer to discoverability
but the problem is if there's not
something
solid behind that it could be a wisp of
smoke
seen today and gone tomorrow so not only
does the youtube paner know how to
generate consistent views but also
consistent revenue
and listen and is not dependent on one
income source
how vulnerable is your youtube business
if you got disapproved for youtube
monetization would your business stop
if advertisers stopped working with you
and brand deals would your business stop
if a certain income stream even beyond
that your merch line
people stopped buying your merch would
your business stop
if you build in this creator economy
a really solid business it's ultimately
not dependent on one income store
source or you have the ability to pivot
because otherwise it's not sustainable
right it's like if if a stream dries up
you're like oh that's it well i guess
we're out of business
you know and you close down shop so the
true youtubepreneur
has these elements right and so
uh ultimately let me ask you
question of the day are you a dabbler
influencer pusher or youtube
preneur which one can you relate to the
most which one can you relate to
the most a youtuber nor has created and
defined a clear vision
of the people they want to help and the
problem they solve
they've mastered getting consistent and
predictable traffic
which means views from youtube they've
mastered generating consistent protect
predictable revenue from youtube
they've tapped into some automation no
business ever grows to any size of
significance if it's required
for one person to keep carrying the
whole thing that one person will burn
out
and this is i hope this just adds value
so you can think about your future
because of course you might be pushing
for
a couple years hustling to get things
going that's the sacrifice season
that everybody in the crater economy mo
or most in the crater economy half
they have to pay the price to get
through that but what are you building
next and what are you ultimately
moving towards the youtuber has mastered
modern marketing and online business
and the youtube entrepreneur listen to
this feeling in this emotion
you know you're starting to approach the
youtube paneur phase
when you don't feel like you're on a
treadmill
headed for burnout i've been on that
treadmill
i've been on that treadmill where i'm
like i don't know if i can keep this up
i feel like i'm on a treadmill
headed for burnout i don't know if this
is sustainable
and thank god that we could maybe even
experience
a couple years of impact on youtube but
think media's mission is to help you
build something really
sustainable that doesn't burn you out
that doesn't crush your family
that doesn't destroy your health that
actually
is built with wisdom so that it can
stand the test of time
whatever that looks like in an internet
age where things move so quickly
but so many influencers are here today
and gone tomorrow
how do we move from being an influencer
to being a youtube preneur
and so the clarity questions is what do
i need to get better at which one do you
relate to
but more than that if you're
got the business model and you're kind
of like generating some money but you
just don't have the views
get obsessed with figuring out how to go
from
you know a a two to a six in views and
the cool thing about the youtube
domination framework
is you could rate yourself right now
you're like listen on a scale from one
to ten
i'm like a three abuse and a zero of
money you know on a scale from one to
ten i'm like a seven of money
for like a one at views and the powerful
thing about that is imagine
if you just move a few steps up the
ladder like if you're like a six at
money
then you go to a one at views you're
doing great the foreign views are doing
amazing you're starting to have impact
at a really really major way uh
by just moving the needle so which out
of these two which one do you need to
get better
at views or or earning money and
figuring out the business model
second question is what is my business
model it's a very important question
many have never
answered the business model what
based on my niche based on my channel
topic based on my strengths
based on my passion based on my vision
based on who i feel called to serve
based on who i want to help based on the
market dynamics
based on my market research to see if
anybody even cares or is interested
in this product or service i want to
create based on all these elements
what is the strategic business model
that i've created
and then also what skill do i need to
learn or improve next
we just talked about it this morning on
our think media team meeting
one of the most important skills we at
think media personally are asking all
the time
one of the most important questions and
one of the most important questions we
encourage our community and our students
answer is what skills do i need to
survive and thrive in the new economy
what skills do i need to survive and
thrive in the new economy
what skills do i need to develop master
and sharpen to win in the creator
economy not just for three months but
for the next three years
13 years and 30 years am i building
something that's
even dependent on a platform i might
leverage the platform and use the
platform today tomorrow and even for the
next eight years but could i withstand
a market shift could i withstand a
pandemic could i withstand
things shifting what skills do i need to
survive and thrive
in the new economy and so i want to know
what is your aha moment from this
training what stood out to you what did
you like best hit like if you've gotten
value and by the way
if you want to learn about our best
advice and my best advice
for your journey to becoming a youtube
preneur we do have a free class
if you haven't seen it yet it's at
thinkmasterclass.com
it's a one hour training that actually
will teach you both sides of
the equation it's the one strategy that
i use to generate
57 346 views per day
think about that that's the views side
of the equation
and then i talk about how to monetize
those views in multiple different ways i
should teach on the different business
models
if you haven't watched it it's at
thinkmasterclass.com and there's a link
in the description down below
and then just so you know i mean i
always want to serve you and be fully
transparent
it's a free class packed with value it's
gonna be one of the most valuable
hours you've probably spent grab a
journal grab a pen at the end of it
i'll tell you a little bit more about
our signature program
called video ranking academy that
actually is an
in-depth course and group coaching
program meaning there's group q a
there's a private group and all these
other things
and just so you know that whether that's
right for you or not
cool check it out watch the free class
learn a little bit about that if all you
want to do is watch the class and
implement the information great
if you don't want to do business with me
or our team awesome
if you do and you recognize like i
really want to get serious and stop
dabbling and start dominating and i
could use some help on the way
awesome we're here to help but it all
starts at thinkmasterclass.com
and so check that out and uh that'll
serve you
and i recently updated that so we leave
the replay up so it's on demand right
now
and i change it uh really about monthly
and so get get it before it it switches
to something differently at
thinkmasterclass.com
where are you at are you a dabbler
influencer pusher or youtubepreneur
let me know uh in the comment section
below
and uh i want to thank you for joining
me today for
coconut water with cannell
so it's not funny uh and coffee with
cannell is the show but it's coconut
water on the menu today
what are you drinking we're gonna bring
on guests in just a second so we're
gonna share
uh the link for you to join and i'd love
to do some q a
with you uh today if you got a question
put four question marks before and after
the question
and i can throw that up on the screen
here in stream yard and i hope you're
doing well
um what do you think about the youtube
domination framework are you ready to
apply that use that
in your own life uh vra fam in the house
good to see you still a dabbler still
learning i love it
uh healthy business tech you're i
appreciate you i hope this was valuable
we got a youtube preneur coming soon
come on it's time to build
uh uh alania i hope i said your name
right appreciate you thanks for being
here
james you got the coffee i got to get
some coffee if you got a question throw
four question marks before and after it
if you see this link in the comments you
can click on it
have a good internet connection good
microphone um and be and you could jump
on and i'd love to answer your questions
here
on um
coffee with cannell coconut water with
cannell and um
let's see mind your matter says my
friend took the ranking academy
watched the free class it was very good
thanks so much for the feedback i'm glad
you've been getting value out of all of
that stuff
we take our work really seriously and we
really believe um
it is the best uh youtube
course and group coaching program on
planet earth
um there's a whole community that
supports you a whole team
because it's not just me because i'm not
just a solo influencer
right the goal was to build something
sustainable that could serve you
and so tony's tip of the week chris
hosting the welcome parties a lot of
stuff's happening inside of our vra
program that you'll really really love
and uh let's see we probably have some
people jumping on
here uh yeah i can probably review some
channels but we're gonna have
um you gotta come on with me though
we're gonna have zach what up zack how's
it going
what's up sean dude i'm uh things are
going good i got some coconut water out
here what are you drinking
a little bit of homemade iced coffee
dude sick is that uh that's that's the
paper
lighting uh photo backdrop that you got
going there right
yes sir it is yes works wonders
i like it so how can i help today um
hey so i have actually had the pleasure
of jumping on one of these with you
before
um which is so cool at the time i think
i was at about
600 subscribers on my channel and i'm
right around
5500 right now kind of like in the
photo video vlog
camera creator kind of space
and um i i've had i've had some
success on like an older video and it's
been kind of taken off
which is super cool about lightroom
mobile and
just trying to um break through
i feel like i'm putting out some content
just kind of had some good steady growth
had a little bit of a dip here recently
and
just trying to i guess kind of carve out
my path try to figure out
kind of like what i mean how much of
like having things blow up or go to the
next level how much of it is
chance how much of it is like just
strategically putting yourself in the
right place or just
the algorithm kind of picks it up
um how many total uploads and how long
you've been going for it
how long have you been not dabbling and
actually like really committed
so i was really committed super strong
pretty much um last year's i've really
only been going at it for a year
and that was just through pandemic and
everything
started going really hard uh towards the
end of last year
beginning of the year started strong and
then uh stuff in life
started to go more towards the dabble uh
i would say i'm more of a dab
fluencer i guess in this space
and so i've been trying sir
dab fluencer a dab
dab like dabbling yeah right got it
uh so it's it's been going for a few
months now and so i'm trying to pick up
consistency
again uh in the space
yeah so i mean your ability to create
content is evident on your channel
you've you've tasted success it's kind
of a good framework because you're like
i've had some banger videos
i mean over a hundred thousand views
didn't change your life
yet you know but it definitely shows
that
um you've kind of tasted winning um
the biggest thing that i want to
encourage you zach
and especially for everybody listening
is that when we make the mindset shift
into
um really not dabbling
into truly dominating and to actually
treating our youtube channel like a
business
we should think about it like a small
business so if i look up
how long does it take for a small
business uh
small biz to
be profitable so
you might know these stats but i'm just
curious like what the latest ones
and my wireless keyboard is
not working how long small business to
be profitable
so let's look at this oh
it takes two to three years
for the average business to be
profitable on
average when a company starts to make
pro profits it depends on how high the
startup costs
are so i think everybody you and
everybody else listening we should think
about that
this you've been doing it for a year
kind of
like i mean and you've been sort of
consistent but you've seen the ups the
downs the dap influencerness a little
bit of dabbling a little bit of results
but think about a small business if i
open up a coffee shop
up the street here in las vegas and i
say i'm going to be open seven days a
week
from 5 00 a.m to 4 p.m so i can hit the
breakfast in the lunch hour
and i'm the manager owner of that coffee
shop
i'm gonna probably find myself there
from 3 a.m
to 6 p.m every single day probably seven
days a week
for the first two to three years now
depending on what kind of money i have
to start up with
i probably take a couple days off
because i've hired
not just baristas but maybe somebody to
be like a shift supervisor
but i'm going to be grinding my face off
for especially those startup years
and i'm not going to be able to take any
days off now i'm not saying don't
rest on sunday or i'm not saying but i'm
not there's no days off
the coffee shop is open the business is
open
i'm not dabbling i'm serious about this
thing
and i'm focused and i have a plan now
i'm not suggesting
that like some toxic hustle culture on
youtube
i'm actually talk suggesting much more
slow and steady consistent
focused strategic work on youtube if you
got 10 hours a week or 20 hours a week
do that you know but but it's seven days
a week
and even the days you're not working are
days you're purposefully resting
because you're building something the
average person
is not building anything i'm not saying
that's bad they're just not
it takes a different kind of person to
be an entrepreneur
to step out to build something to stay
focused and
i say all that for all of us here in the
think community but also for you
specifically
because the insights are there the
strategies are there
you've had past success there's a
million approaches and i'll recommend
our think media library or our
freethinkmasterclass.com to you
because there's a lot of approaches in
how to get views but i think more than
anything with the results you've gotten
your ability to create content i want to
speak to you more
the man the leader that just steps up
and says okay
i'm gonna plan this thing out i'm gonna
be consistent on this thing
i'm gonna put out a quality video a week
i'm gonna find a way to put out
two videos a week or six videos a month
i'm going to strategically reach out for
some collaborations with people
i'm going to really be disciplined with
my calendar and my time blocking
i'm a freaking business owner i've got a
two to three
run three year runway before i hit this
profitability threshold
and if i don't hit it in startup culture
it's called burn rate
they get seed funding and it's a
countdown clock to death
unless they get more seed funding
because they'll run out of money and
they're totally
focused you could even this is a major
disclaimer i'm not suggesting you take
out a small business loan
right by any means but that's what small
businesses do
is they take out because they need
capital
to pay the employees to pay themselves
to run the business
for the two years to hit profitability
and that'd be my advice to you and
a lot of that's personalized to you
because the skills you have
the set you're coming to me on the
videos you've already published
bro it's just on the other side of
execution of the hard work and of the
focus killing every distraction
killing every little like worthless side
project or side thing that's not going
directly to that specific target
of growth and profitability that gives
you the freedom
to not only say cool now i'm able to
work on this full-time or
you know i've got that autonomy but i
also have a little bit of breathing room
maybe some time to reinvest in
delegating some things or some systems
but zach
is that resonating with you at all oh
100 man
yeah i think just that whole
perspective shift is just really
beneficial
to really think of it like it's a
business and
i mean i've heard it said about before i
don't know you probably talked about
this
but just even when it comes to views and
like an audience
if it's a hundred views it's like think
of 100 people in front of you
if you were talking to them and so i
think that that's
huge i mean definitely something i need
to hear right now just kind of that
whole
perspective shift and then just cutting
out the distractions and just
going going all in on it i love it zach
and and and i really do believe in you
and appreciate what you're doing again i
know we talked before
and i was remembered when i saw that uh
that video you did
uh with the sony webcam that went well i
think we we talked about that one last
time how that
had blown up and so bro it's in you and
then for a practical tip of the day
coffee with kennel tip of the day
welcome to the new segment success
leaves clues
so make part twos um
tip of the day is you know you probably
are doing more lightroom
mobile stuff but like your top video is
lightroom mobile
which means that's also the majority of
your subscribers
like i'm sure that you're driven the
most subscribers so what are they
clicking the subscribe button for
lightroom so like more lightroom or and
specifically lightroom mobile
so i don't know if you've done a 25 part
series on lightroom
yet uh but there's there's that idea
and so but for everybody watching what
is your most successful video
and success leaves clues so make part
twos double down spin off on it um
your most successful videos tr probably
driven your most subscribers
and i'm not really seeing enough
lightroom mobile stuff here i'm super
discouraged i mean a little bit is this
and is this big lightroom or baby
lightroom big lightroom
yeah i mean lightroom mobile man like
and i i think that
you know it's literally your top video
my wireless keyboard
is not functioning oh here we go uh
lightroom
mobile presets lightroom mobile tutorial
lightroom mobile editing lightroom
mobile
uh photo editing lightroom
portrait editing lightroom mobile color
grading like that's your series
because 30 50
of your 6 000 subscribers would want to
watch that probably
right zach i appreciate you man thanks
so much for coming on
thanks sean always appreciate it brother
all right take care
hey coffee with candle crew
success leaves clues so make part twos
and uh
smash the like button if you're getting
value today
man thank you uh influential finance
it's a
that's a funny one mobile look at people
are demanding it too zach
make more people want to subscribe it's
funny
um you know one of the principles that
we shared at the beginning of this year
in our youtube strategy workshop um
was uh which is something you know our
video ranking academy that we do for
them right
is um the creator who understands the
viewer best wins
and it's just so true and what's funny
is if you just shrug that off and say
okay cool or i've heard you say that
before
dude you're on a you're gonna stop your
growth you can't exhaust the potency of
that phrase and what it should mean to
your actions
the creator you who understands the
viewer the audience you're trying to
reach
best wins and what i've learned
is most really don't understand who
they're talking to
i think about it like marriage or
relationships have you ever been in a
relationship
you have a partner where you're like
were you even listening to me
like you were talking like my wife told
me this last night
she was like yeah on sunday i told you
this this and this and i was like
exactly i heard you say
i could repeat it back to you she's like
yeah but were you listening
did you actually get what i was saying
were you reading between the lines and i
was like listen honey
our counselor taught us that women speak
speak pink
men speak blue i need you sometimes not
just to communicate with me but to
translate
not just what you said but what you mean
because as intelligent as you think i am
i'm not that smart
i'm out here grunting you know what am i
doing today
man you know not to just push into
stereotypes
cancel sean listen
do you really understand the viewer
and the audience you want to reach and
i'm not suggesting zack is way off track
but if
if his audience and most viewed video is
lightroom mobile it's sitting right in
front of him in play dangling play
playing daylight success leaves clues
make part twos
but he hasn't made the 24-part lightroom
mobile does that make sense
you're making you're making things
people aren't even asking for
hear me there's maybe other people on
youtube where meantime
meanwhile the there's people there that
are like could i have some more
lightroom mobile content please
right it's like the five love languages
i'm like honey
i've been encouraging you honey we've
spent some quality time together
and she's like sean my love language is
gifts
so even though i appreciate these other
love languages you're talking to me
anybody read the five love languages by
gary chapman come on give me
and even though you're talking to me in
these other love languages
you're not filling my tank up with my
actual love language it's like what's
your audience's love language
what's the viewers love languages what
is the questions they're actually asking
do you really understand them and 99 out
of 100 creators myself
included on most days is actually out of
touch
you ever seen a politician that's out of
touch have you ever seen a celebrity
that's been
out of touch on their social media have
you ever seen a kardashian post
something
that is out of touch not trying to call
out kardashians
disconnected out of touch the more in
touch
intimate close and understanding of the
person you're trying to reach and serve
and their pain points and their
ambitions
and you're creating content around that
that's where the magic is
it's hard work it's not like oh uh i got
it in a moment now i have the key
it's a lifelong journey this is the
lifestyle of youtubepreneurs
is constantly thinking about how they
can better understand and serve
their ideal viewer that they want to
help
solve their problems and reach their
ambitions i hope that was valuable smash
like if you're grateful to be alive we
got janna coming up
janna in the house nice great hey
how are you doing i'm doing super good
i'm coming to las vegas i'm curious
where you are you got sound paneling
you got some studio monitors on the desk
what do you do and uh where are you
streaming from yeah i'm streaming from
my office but i can tell you here is my
we have a whole studio here with
production for electronic music and
this here is my little space where i
always record my videos um
exactly we're working with sound and
sound um
recordings and yeah so i'm from spain
i'm here it's afternoon i'm in spain
amazing well how can i help today do you
have a channel i can pull
up um yeah sure i dropped the link here
in the
in the private chat no okay let me find
it
go and then drop your question i got it
quantity okay
yeah so right now i'm really i just i
really loved what you just said about
the love story
the love language that comparison with
the relationship that you give so much
and in the end it's not the language and
the pocket doesn't get
filled up so um yeah i'm just beginning
as you see i got 300 subscribers
and um i really yeah i'm around
life coaching and i just got a new
header done
and the banner these are frequencies
we produce they are um
frequency for consciousness for changing
the frequency field
and they have 11 hours long yeah it's
all night uh you put it all night so um
uh people actually really like this the
first breakthrough
video i had was an eight hour alpha wave
yeah okay yeah so as you see these are
the two that got really pushed out
i don't know what what what went wrong
because um
yeah i think i know i stopped putting
videos weekly
some weeks ago because i was involved in
a challenge i did and
and i think youtube cut me a little bit
all of a sudden i got no growth of
subscribers and my videos all stopped so
i said i have to get back on track i
recorded three new videos today
to be uploading regularly again
so awesome so how can i help do you just
want my feedback or do you have a
specific question
uh yeah actually i just yesterday
finished the
the header um how do you do you see this
do you see there's too much information
is this overwhelming for the user
or um do you do you see this clear
and gotcha yeah so let's talk about it
so
yeah that is my initial thing there
there is
uh is a little bit of
overwhelm um so the best way i'd like to
think about it is
first of all um the i think the design
overall
there's there's so many words from the
thumbnails
my eye feels pulled in a lot of
different
directions you know i feel like i'm
going a lot of different places
um i think study youtube channels and
this is one of your goals too you're
helping people get into a place of peace
probably declutter their mind you know
things like that i want you to declutter
the channel like you know i want you to
uh to bring a little bit more simplicity
and clarity to it
um there's a lot of good channels you
could study uh
think media not that we do things
perfect perfectly
but what we also are trying to do here
at least our strategy on our cover
is number one kind of show that we're a
team
show show not tell in terms of imaging
that we do cameras we do lighting but we
don't need to say camera or whatever
um show that you're gonna learn about
youtube there's me speaking you know and
then
weekly tips and tools for building your
influence online
this is kind of i don't actually believe
cover image is ultimately like we'll
make or break your channel
but i think the power of making a strong
cover image
and writing a really strong about page
is the process it'll force you to go
through
of getting very clear and trying to
simplify your vision your
mission and your message okay so yeah
yeah
that's what we're trying to do here and
then if you notice
the way the aesthetic of you know
youtube channel is like a web page your
youtube channel is a web page
and the only visual graphical element
of your youtube quote unquote web page
is thumbnails
so to try to keep it as clean as
possible
try to remove words from the thumbnails
whatever possible so we oftentimes will
go no words the last two videos have no
words besides the words on the product
itself here the numbers on the calendar
and then you know with nolan short and
long so i would like to see
some of um i would like to see some
simplicity there
i think the other thing is you know you
got this whole studio you're world class
at at the music side of things you're
making these videos
which is also uh let's see you've got
great you're creating content you know
uh wherever you go is this kind of like
a royalty three
free graphic you downloaded and looped
yeah exactly it's raw your free royalty
free stuff
cool so and i said okay so i see you
doing that you're able to create videos
here so all that's looking good
i would invest this also for everybody
else
you know there's probably plenty of free
tutorials on youtube but earlier on we
asked
what skills do i need to learn next
i would just do a little bit of a
skillshare course or some free youtube
videos
on like do you use canva or what do you
use to make your thumbnails
photoshop oh if you're doing photoshop
so you know level up your photoshop
skills a little bit simplify
your thumbnails a little bit maybe
invest a little bit of photography
yeah the photos are actually of you are
super clean and crispy
but like the evolution of that you know
i like a little bit more of the pigment
in your skin here versus that
these are not things that are going to
make or break your channel but well the
tricks you
shared with the 30 intensity that i got
these from your video from one
oh okay so you did it and then
ultimately
you know it's it's what i would also
study like uh one friend of mine
is chris doe uh in the future and i mean
it'll take you down all kind of rabbit
holes but uh sometimes it's playlists on
design
like if you even they're up this is
their greatest skill set is design
itself so they're really clean banner
they got the you know simple up there
and then
like look at this unlock your mind i
could see a thumbnail you doing a
thumbnail like that like
good use of text real minimalist looks
you know even here these are simple
they're clean
and so um homework for you and others
study some youtube channels in your
niche
key outside of your niche brainstorm
some of the things you want to create
and don't be afraid to quote unquote
copy
good artist copy great artist steal to
say
okay let me try to make this thumbnail i
mean i'm going to do a blue i'm going to
use a slightly different font i'm going
to find a slightly different image
but let me just kind of use this as a
template because i haven't been studying
design my whole life like chris
doe but yeah i like this is a model
that i could you know kind of step
inside and i think that would really
level up the the clarity of just your
overall branding and what's happening
on your channel does that make sense
that makes perfect sense
and sean i have something that is really
uh heavy on me that uh can i ask another
thing and ask
you okay i am speaking three languages i
speak
german english and spanish and my my
ideal is to have a multilingual
youtube channel because i have people in
germany people in spain
and people in english because it's the
word language
so my question is actually is this
possible
would you recommend to have a
multilingual
youtube channel or would you say that
it's better to grow
in one language and then later on create
like a separate channel in a separate
language
yeah the problem with the multilingual
youtube channel is one of the principles
we try to live by think is we never want
to upload a video our subscribers didn't
subscribe for
so the problem is yeah multiple
languages
is unless especially if they if they
spoke the same three languages
german english and spanish you would say
unless you told me sean
my ideal subscriber and the only person
i want to subscribe to my channel
speaks german english and spanish we
probably just know the population much
smaller
because if i upload a video
in english okay some of my audience
likes it but those that have maybe
found a video that had a german title
and you spoke german in it
and they go i don't speak english or you
know then there's a spanish one and they
don't speak
you're uploading videos that some of
your audience does not even understand
yeah unless your target audience
is bilingual which there may be this is
where it just comes back to like having
clarity of what you're actually building
my best advice is pick one i think
there's massive opportunity
if it's a german channel german titles
german tags german description speak
german german on the cover german and
the thumbnails
all german people who speak german
subscribe to the channel you upload a
video
they speak german it's all good it's
focused but don't
also then if you start throwing spanish
especially by the way you don't also
pivot later
you get 100 000 subscribers you're like
now let me start uploading spanish
videos and all your subscribers are like
i don't understand these
so if you never upload a video your
subscribers didn't subscribe for
you really want to pick a language and
go deep it doesn't have to be
english but in my opinion it should be
just one language
you sure okay i i that was the question
what was your opinion on that yeah okay
and then you say later when the english
one goes uh maybe start a separate
channel and
start a separate channel and you have to
realize that that also might have
diminishing
returns or it may take a lot of energy
but it depends on the team and systems
you have around i'll give you an example
a lot of people know who garyvee has 3
million subscribers
if you look at channels he's got gary
vee espanol
he's got garyvee brazil he's got gary
vee
uh and this is maybe arabic right and
maybe
japanese or chinese and and so he also
brazil only has seven thousand subs
uh espanol only has nineteen 000 i'm
gonna see how consistent he's being over
here
hasn't uploaded for a month and gary vee
has over 30 employees
working on his personal brand some
people don't understand garyvee he has
over a thousand employees
working in his businesses but he has 30
full-time people helping him
just on his personal brand to chop up
content to post content to
uh cut up thumbnails to help him with
projects to help him with writing
so the point is the time you actually
launch the spanish channel you got to
ask
how much time do you need how much money
do you need to get the help and how much
how much of a distraction would that be
off of your main thing
i'm not suggesting you shouldn't do it
but even gary hasn't uploaded in a month
let's check one of his other channels
and he has 30 people uh working for him
yeah so
you think you get like one part-time
person helping you're gonna be able to
sustain like
starting a whole nother channel in a
different you know language yeah
you know maybe not right and so so just
the practicality of it
it's not that again you should never do
it
uh but it's that it may and again this
is the this is a great example
when you pick a language cover title
text gary v chinese it the whole deal
like it's all in thumbnails you think
about the amount of work that goes into
doing this right and
you know three weeks ago they're
dropping one here they're dropping one
there
and um and again he's got 30 people and
the dollars
and the revenue and he gets paid uh you
know
over 50k to 80k or more for
virtual uh events just to speak in some
earpods and gets
paid over 100k for keynote events so
he's got the capital to reinvest
in his business it just may be out of
reach for us and that
this is one of the traps that keep us in
kind of that
influencer or that pusher that dabbling
stage
we got to get really clear on our
business model and we have to stay so
relentlessly focused um because if you
do want to hit those other things i
would say
if you said here's the interview
questions i would say
do you have jana too
much time like you just got so much time
like it's it's annoying how much and
then two
janna do you have too
much money like you are so
frustrated by the amount of
money that is overwhelming you if you
say
yes to both of those questions
while your business is operating on its
own and autopilot your youtube channel
and all that stuff's happening
then you should start the channel the
spanish channel that's like that's the
time
kind of branch off and do the new thing
until that time
stay focused okay and so right now
my um the last thing i will say thanks
for your time
right now the thing is my fans the among
the 300
are spanish and german but
i feel that my channel should be in
english so what happens i upload a video
and the spanish people
they see the video they start watching
five seconds
and they say oh it's in english and they
turn it off which is really bad for the
metrics as you
explained yesterday in the other video
too you know they they watch it they say
it's not my language so that is my
conflict right now to
to get this push because i published a
video and then
they don't understand it you know what i
mean and they leave and it's bad for the
metrics
and i believe i'm caught in this maybe
it's it's an illusion
what is your advice should i just keep
pushing now in english
and just keep doing it or or would you
say
adjust now to the audience you have
brilliant
so as we land the plane
what you need to do you already
expressed you said my clarity and
commitment
is that i think we need to do this in
english but when i upload it for
those that are speaking spanish because
of some of the things i've done in the
past
they click off the video here's the
reality of where you're at but i don't
care if you're at
300 subs 3 000 subs or 30 000 subs
you just told me the clarity yes the
algorithm
algorithm yes everything else but that's
the influencer trap
yeah but my followers up into this point
want this so i should also do that
and then yeah and and that's that's the
wrong question the right question
is what am i building where am i going
what language is it going to be
and you just make the commitment yeah
thank you so much yeah you got it jen
does that make sense
yeah makes perfect sense thank you that
is it has been on my mind for so many
months now and i don't
can't believe i got in here now and i
got you to ask you this question thank
you so much for
you got it yeah you got it thanks so
much for coming on i appreciate you so
much
thank you thank you john we have denise
coming on in just a second
quick story about that though
um what's your vision what are you
building
and are you placating to get views to
get algorithms
to to please the algorithm um
i want to honor your struggle in getting
to 300 subs
a thousand subs 1 300 subs one of the
traps i see people get in though
is they have 1 300 subscribers and they
start talking about
man you know but if i change my content
strategy
my subscribers are going to be mad now
hear me honor your subscribers
it's great that 1300 people have come
along for the journey
but you need to have the clarity and
conviction to know where you're going
even if it makes people that have been
with you this far upset
you're never going to be able to please
everybody and i learned this
because i've served in church and
ministry for so long
and i grew up in a small town arlington
washington and marysville washington an
hour north of seattle
if you've ever been a part of a small
church 200 people
100 people then what you know in
leadership is that
as things go along in your church there
might come up a time where you say you
know what
we've been playing older hymn music for
so long i want it like an electric
guitar
and a drum set and like some lights to
be a little bit more contemporary so we
can step into the year that we're living
in
inevitably once you put that drum set up
there if your church is super
traditional and you can put that
electric guitar up there
bertha from the women's ministry is
gonna be like
um the lord doesn't like
drum music and guitar and you're like um
bertha i don't actually see that in the
scriptures but i am sorry
and then what happens is rick you know
who's been a part of the church for a
long time
he's just been used to the where where
his seat's been he's been used to wear
the
carpet color but after you one day as a
leadership team you go you know what
i think we need to change the carpet in
this church it's stained it's old it's a
pattern from 1983
and it's 20 21 it's time to change the
carpet but rick's kind of upset now
because he's like wait a minute
i've been sitting in that seat this
whole time i like the carpet the way
that it was
like what the heck are you doing with
the carpet and now
hear me i'm not dishonoring bertha or
rick
these people have been a part of your
journey
but you have to have the conviction of
as a leader
to communicate where you're going why
you're going there
but also to make a decision that may not
please everybody and the truth
is the carpet needs to change and the
music should probably become a little
bit more contemporary
do you see the power of the analogy so
sometimes
it's not us being flippant or arrogant
but it's
us knowing where we want to go and
and to have a sustainable business on
youtube
a couple hundred subscribers is not
enough in my opinion
eventually you don't need a hundred
thousand but you probably need more than
a hundred
and so sometimes if you're just focused
on those that are there you're not gonna
make the right decisions
necessary to reach those that you're
called to reach
and you have to be willing to offend or
get uncomfortable with bertha
and rick in the middle in order to reach
into the future and that's the hard
leadership decision
and hopefully you're like listen rick
dawg you can still have your chair
you know like it's it's we we appreciate
you being a part of the church the
carpet stinks dude
like this carpet smells so bad and it's
ugly
like we're just changing the carpet it's
not that big of a deal you know like the
elder board is like if we paint the
walls
you're like dude it's just paint and of
course you're you're knowing
how to communicate to them well and
you're like bertha listen
don't you want your grandkids and their
children's children
to like know the power that god has had
in our life and the transformation power
of the bible
if we don't change the music up a little
bit
like we're just not going to reach them
at all so
bertha begins to catch the vision or she
doesn't she gets offended and she leaves
either way the future was forward either
way you need to make your future bigger
than your past
and so i just want to encourage you not
just in terms of making a decision about
what language to make your videos and
what
the the the viewers on youtube you're
called to reach are
are um you know all about in the future
not just the ones that are there
but to have courage and conviction to
define where you're going what your
vision is
and then work towards it denise how's it
going where are you watching from
and how can i help today hi i'm walking
from indiana
and it's going pretty good i my youtube
channel was this and that with denise
jordan
and i teach traditional homemaking to
today's homemaker
and it is growing and there's probably
people on here that would say
what you complaining about but it's
growing
slowly and i just feel like somewhere
i'm missing the mark i'm just off
just a little bit but one of the things
oh my god but one of the things that i
did do
is i did based upon your teaching i do
have a
business model now and i sell aprons
which i was shooting a video before i
came on
so that's why i'm you know kind of like
you know in my persona
but i just feel like i'm missing the
mark
somewhere okay
so grateful you're here denise love what
you're doing it also said includes paid
promotion what was the brand deal on
that video
oh coldest water what's that uh it's a
water bottle it's a coldest water they
sell water bottles and other gear to
keep
water um and
other drinks cold okay so
i love it well let's let's let's start
with a few questions
let's let's get clear on what winning
looks like um
you feel like it's not growing fast
enough you feel like
it's you're maybe doing something wrong
that's a valid question
but let me ask you what is your ultimate
end goal
is it to be able to work on this full
time are you working on this full-time
now
i'm working on a full-time now i'm
retired so i don't
use this as an income i started out
dabbling but now i'm ready to dominate
i want to be like come on
it's time it's time to dominate be like
so so
there's actually not financial need nope
although you're generating finances
you're building a business model you got
a sponsor you're getting some youtube ad
revenue correct
so would you say what is your
mission with this channel my mission is
to teach
young homemakers how to be homemakers
because so many of the
young people today don't know how to
make a home or to keep a home yep
okay so your your mission is impact your
mission is i want to impact as many
people possible and
i just want to affirm your vision's
incredible and so
true i know we sometimes get stereotyped
whether it's
i'm a millennial or gen z that we don't
know how to do anything we don't know
how to cook it's been a good year for
postmates we don't know how to
make a home so it's total chaos or we're
on
taskrabbit trying to solve the problem
you know i'm grateful i grew up my
stepdad
had me taking transmissions out of jeeps
and fiction tractors with him
and my mom made me do all kind of stuff
we grew up on a farm so
i don't even think i'm near this and
that with denise jordan but at least
i kind of feel like i'm in a hybrid and
i definitely see the
need of the things that you're teaching
i mean
the first thing i'd encourage you how
long you've been doing this how many
uploads
i probably upload well i was trying to
upload
two videos a week and then i started a
show so i had two uploads a week plus
the show
um in the middle of the week and then i
had another
channel that i just do a little bit of
dabbling with some with a circle of
friends but i just got to the point that
i am just
feeling so overwhelmed with even the two
uploads a week and the show it's like i
just can't seem to
plus starting the apron business it all
takes time
and energy yep
and total uploads we can look
oh i've got over 500 uploads
156. yeah i've been working at this
rise and grind come on let's go denise
that's that's i i just like that right
for everybody watching that
has uploaded seven and is complaining
they need to realize that denise
jordan has 756 uploads
it's time to get on your grind talking
to everybody on coffee with kennel
all right so though haven't done as well
it's like i'm missing the mark somewhere
it could be
some of the content that i'm using
lately i don't know
sure yeah we'll dive into that so here
we go number one
before we even get into things i'm not
trying to be sound contrived here
but the first thing i want to really
challenge you in
is patience and gratitude
i'm not insinuating that you don't have
that but like
there's some there's a lot of people
around the world that would
kill for these results like that's not
it's not right to kill people and they
would literally like
knife someone in the lobby i'm joking
right this is a joke
but you know you know 46 000 views
a month 500 new subscribers a month
it's you're getting great results you
also
you're accomplishing your mission yes
and i don't know if you're like this but
i know a lot of us are like this when
we're type a driven
and when we want to make a difference
we are always looking on the next thing
which is good because that's what pulls
us into the future
sometimes we blow right past the impact
the incredible results
the moments of celebrating you have 2.2
million views on your channel and so
just kind of the patience and gratitude
of this
like i know you would never settle you
don't sound like that person i know you
would never get
comfortable i'm sure you're content but
you'd never be complacent
but there's something about even
considering being content
we're going to blow past that like
you're growing
if you grow 500 new subscribers a month
and you keep going
that's thousands of people every year
like you're going to get to 100 000
subscribers
it just might take time you'll get to
250 000 it just might take time
we're about to talk about how to go
faster but i want to encourage you with
that first because there is just
so many results and so much impact
already
surrounding this and if you're not
falling short of a financial goal
and if you're comfortable in retirement
in terms of financially
like i think it's time to like
have a special dinner in honor of what
you've accomplished so far
does that make sense it does it does
okay secondly because you're like all
right great well give me some tactics
though dog i'm trying to get it going
uh i think the second thing is focus
and that is that you know
you've been doing this long enough that
you mentioned a couple things to me
how many times how many hours a week are
you devoting to this since you are able
to do it full-time
oh um and do you want to like if you're
feeling overwhelmed you might be pushing
past that threshold
so how many hours are you actually
devoting to it
probably would you like to are plus
ideal
i'm probably devoting at least 20 hours
a week because by the time you look at
editing
you know the shooting and then the
editing and then the uploading and then
the video
all of it it it could even be more than
that for the two uploads the show the
apron and the second channel
oh gosh probably 30.
yeah and how many do you want to like so
you can
have a sustainable impact but also live
the life and have
a pace that's not just making the impact
but it also feels healthy for you and
you don't feel overwhelmed
if you had your ideal amount of hours
per week
probably 15 yeah okay
so before we even dive into anything we
need to audit
what you're even up to you have allowed
things to get a little bit complex
if you could tell me that the second
channel that you do with friends
is not overwhelming
and is refreshing and is
outside of the scope of the main thing
in the main mission that you're building
as far as impact
and it's something that you then then
it's something you should consider stop
doing
because it's taking away
from you making your next best video in
your main
project now of course you can do
whatever you want like as we all can
but it's something and i want to
challenge the think community to say
what do you need to stop doing ask
yourself the same questions about how
many hours you actually have how many
hours you are spending how many hours
you want to spend
and then ask what you could cut away
the aprons you're committed to so you
know you got to chip away at that
and you've started this show do you
enjoy doing the show
i do i do enjoy doing the show it takes
research
it takes time i'm building a community
and a lot of young homemakers jump on
there so it's my target audience
so i do enjoy the show
so at least we should probably cancel
for now and that's a key for now until
we get a little more leverage a little
more momentum
we should cancel uh or or put on hold
the second channel
um we should then make you know get the
apron business as automated as possible
and then now you're looking at the show
and two uploads for what you're up to
i would i love the volume you're putting
out
but i think that it's about quality over
quantity
i know you're saying some videos aren't
doing as well i would rather you have
one
with everything you know after 756
uploads plus all the
training and everything i would rather
say if there was like two videos you're
like that one's kind of weak and i sort
of want to do it but that one's like
that's a really good title and people
are really
wanting that um and i would focus maybe
on one great upload a week and one show
a week
doing the key doing less
better and maybe settling into 15
20 hours a week so you're more refreshed
the less
is better you you are your best and i
also think it'll actually lead to more
results simplicity
is power and simplicity will actually
ultimately bring
speed and so then i would say number
three and we said it earlier
success leaves clues make part twos um
when i look at of course this is all of
our dreams
is that when our new uploads don't have
300 views or 700 views
but eventually they get 71 000 views or
77 000 views
how often are you looking back at what
you can learn from your most popular
videos
not often i rarely do because
there's obvious there's a lot of stuff
the homemade disinfectant
the hand sanitizer there's different
things
you and i've noticed this is uh
this would be a final tip that a lot of
us
are sometimes afraid of quote unquote
making the same video
for those that have been around think
media you've probably
you sometimes go dude you sometimes kind
of make the the same video it's maybe a
fresh angle
it's maybe a fresh perspective but we do
what works and we do what people are
asking for
if you actually look at the largest
independent youtuber pewdiepie
it's actually like a meme and a joke in
his community that he just makes
like the same types of videos he does
like reaction videos like you laugh you
lose
or he makes the videos reacting to uh
tlc shows
um or like he does a lot of
quote-unquote repetitive content but
it's
always fresh jokes it's always a fresh
so i actually think
there's something about going deeper
into the topics
into and even remaking here's the key
remaking your greatest hits
you have a two years old video on on
soft and fluffy towels maybe it's not
the exact same title
but it's something about going back and
they've already been proven to be the
top sellers
what does a restaurant do when a dish is
the top seller they don't go okay well
let's try to do something different and
move it off the menu they take a picture
of it and they make it the main thing
and they even double down
on the things that are working most and
so
um i would you know i would look at what
you can learn from your top videos maybe
make a part
two or a fresh version and and two years
later
your camera's gonna look a little bit
different your title might be a little
bit different your thumbnail might be a
little bit evolved
and you have a chance to double down
on that video and uh and get some more
views and then the final thing
more than title more than thumbnails
is sort of what we're talking about what
i think is the most important
important is topic
kind of doesn't surprise me that first
garden walk
i don't think that'll be the biggest
video because
it's not notice like the you were
answering specific questions asq
when you were teaching people how to do
hand sanitizer which is accomplishing
your mission
of helping people be homemakers whereas
over here
your your subscribers are pumped about
this it's this is what's hard because as
a leader you have to make a decision
like
okay i want to put this out and hear me
if this refreshes your soul and you're
enjoying it you can
but it actually doesn't surprise me that
this won't be a massively successful
video in your library it's not the same
framework in terms of your highest
performers which most of
are are hot are how to prepper
in regards to definitely during the pan
that's understanding what's happening in
culture
um a practical video about how to you
know make
like answering specific questions
solving very specific
problems the disinfectant and the hand
sanitizer
i'm sure did well through the pandemic
it looks like you did them a year ago so
so that goes back to
making some space
getting some things off your calendar
simplifying so you're not maxing out
your energy at 30 hours and feeling
overwhelmed
doing less better and making some
calculated moves to say
okay here's the next 10 videos i want to
make which of these
topics could be the strongest
and or will and your intuition if you
just ask that one question
you might be like well i could do the
garden walk through and this is the
discipline
if you want to check out and not edit
the video and
and be done at 15 hours that took time
to do that video
whereas if instead you just made one how
to make homemade disinfectant video and
it got 100
000 views then if you're if you're how
to walk through the garden video
that'll maybe stay stuck at a thousand
views you just got a hundred
times the impact of the time invested
for making a seven minute video i
realize you can't plan every video to be
a hundred thousand but do you see what i
mean
being more calculated on what's
happening
what what does my what would my audience
click on what would they go after
i know i said we're going to land the
plane you know i the
one other thing i would do over here on
your community tab is i'd throw
a ton of quizzes i'd use a lot of
quizzes
um and and i don't see any right here
the best performing community tab posts
are going to be surveys but don't just
you know you can grow into them but
your audience will tell you the creator
understands the viewer best wins
okay maybe you narrow it down to four
videos you want to make
do you want to see my garden walk
through do you want to see this do you
want to learn how to make
hand sanitizer you know and you're like
okay i thought but they said
and so that's also a practical way when
you make the right
topics do less videos but do
higher quality videos for he
for the stage you're at after 756
uploads in my
mind it's about refining your approach
now
as opposed to kind of taking a shotgun
approach
and seeing what sticks and i believe
you've got that clarity within you
you've your cover is amazing your
consistency and hustle is incredible
i love what you're doing you are
destroying everybody watching this
video's excuses with your amount of
hustle and persistence and uploads
but as we evolve in our youtube business
sometimes it's more about refining
than it is just about grinding to put
out as much volume and do a show and do
two videos and go on a second channel
and do so much
really take some time to simplify your
plan for this next season and i believe
you're gonna crush it
okay thank you that makes so much sense
and i've been spending a lot of time
the past couple of days just kind of
thinking about what i shared with you
about missing the mark and thinking
about well what my homemakers want to
see and i was thinking okay so maybe
five tips to you know a clean house or
something like that or how to have a
productive morning but more things
like that because i thought obviously
you know the garden walk
didn't hit it yeah okay more specific
things that and answering some of the
questions that they've had in my
comments too answer specific questions
do some of those community tab surveys
those will be fun
and uh and and i saw a great comment
here too
our community's so amazing her food
dishes are really popular she should
make dishes using ingredients grown from
her garden
so success leaves clues make part twos
okay and uh less content better content
and by better i don't your videos i'm
sure are great it's it's not
you know how to teach you know how to
instruct it's the right topic
it's like it's the videos that they want
to click on uh
and actually watch as opposed to maybe
some of the ones you feel like making
but won't do the best
okay thank you i appreciate that i
appreciate uh appreciate you denise
thanks so much for coming on
okay uh my friend smash like if you're
getting uh value out of this
i am going to take a little bit more
time
it's a time to sing like a broadway show
what okay so i have a meeting in about
30 minutes we're gonna hit a few more
people up
if you're getting value though smash the
like button if you're if you're glad
that coconut water with candle is back
i'm excited to be here
father with an eight and a half month
old trying to make it out here today's
episode is brought to you by think media
uh thinkmasterclass.com if you haven't
watched it
that's a great to do this list help you
with keyword research making the right
videos finding the right topics how to
build
multiple different income streams around
your content think masterclass.com is
where you can watch that for free
links in the description down below to
watch that you can just type the word
think or master class into your browser
and it'll take you there
or in the youtube description of this
video there's a clickable link
that will take you over where you can
watch that free
web class all right we got stephanie
she's been patiently waiting
i see you nicole daniel and ray we're
gonna do our best to get as far as we
can
today stephanie how's it going hi
how can i help i am in spring texas my
question is this
i've been doing my channel for a while
but i started being really consistent
the last
maybe i want to say three years and
i'm kind of frozen it's like tick tock
tick tock tick tock with subscribers and
views
and i've changed my thumbnails some
people said no picture
picture no name no name no title so i've
changed them over and over again to get
see if i was doing it correctly also
i've changed my channel art
i don't know i don't know what i'm doing
that's not drawing enough people in
to view my videos i'm kind of frozen and
it's a little frustrating
yeah i got it let's dive in and thank
you so much for being here first of all
um you're doing just some incredible
things i love your avatar it's clear
the yellow dress pops banner image is
clear
to me decorating on a budget i think
everybody watching this
should learn from that promise um
because it's a simple promise and it's
explicitly clear um i think
that one thing i want to talk about
before what comes before titles and they
matter
what becomes before thumbnails of course
that matters
um is is the content itself i like to
think about
content with a training we're coming up
with uh or releasing in the future at
our event growth video live called the
perfect video recipe
and it's this if you think about cooking
up a youtube video like cooking up
a really good dish ultimately
it's the dish that matters most if we've
ever taken a bite of food and we've been
like oh
shoot uh okay and we kind of high we
don't you throw the whole thing away you
ordered it online or hopefully you don't
just throw it away in front of the
person who's entertaining us because
their food is bad
at the end of the day it's the food that
matters most when you eat it it
satisfies you when the viewer consumes
your video we want them to enjoy that
content now
if the a restaurant has the best food in
the well
in the world but their yelp pictures
you're like ooh that place looks
dingy right that that dish doesn't look
good it could be amazing but that's the
thumbnail
if the name of the dish or the name of
the restaurant or how easy it is to find
on yelp or on google maps
if if we break down there that's why
content is king
but marketing is queen and she runs the
household
right because it's the content's got to
be good
but the marketing that leads to it is so
important because they'll never walk
into the restaurant doors
if they uh if it's not the thumbnail the
topic etc
and so let's actually just take a moment
here and
let me check out uh let's check this
video out
[Music]
okay so first thing this isn't gonna
necessarily make or break
your videos although i think it could
the opening of your video was 10 seconds
long
of no value that just wasted my time
and the viewers time so don't start your
videos
with uh well i used to start my video
with me saying you know uh what my video
was going to be about
good good good and this but you see what
i'm saying here so like this
and it's like it doesn't add really any
and and people are moving fast there's a
really good book
um and we interviewed um his name's
brendan kane so
if you haven't listened to our think
media podcast we have a weekly podcast
on audio
and here on the uh think media channel
his name is brennan kane
the book's called hook point it revealed
that we now live in a three second world
where we have to get attention in three
seconds and so
this is 10 seconds and it sounds like on
your other videos
but i would say two things i don't know
if you even need an intro
your intro should be three to five
seconds not ten no matter where it is
okay and so that'll trim things down but
let's keep it going
hello friends this is stephanie of
creatively miss me
this is your first time visiting my
channel welcome i'm so glad you're here
here i share decorating and home
organization tips
now this is your kind of content i would
love for you to subscribe and become
part of the family
and to my creative family i want to
thank you for your continuing support
now in today's video i am decorating my
summer tablescape
so i hope you eat okay really good so i
like i love the graphics you're doing i
like the editing you're doing
um from a cinematographer uh
or just i have background in video and
photo i wasn't i wasn't super pumped
about the opening shot
in terms of me walking in front of the
camera
well not even that just first the shot
was empty so it kind of took me a while
before i saw most
uh saw saw much of anything but here's
the
the model that we want to go after on a
video like this people are looking for a
transformation
so so what what they should see
potentially
and we could so i hit this from a couple
sides
first of all the best videos would
probably be how to solve a problem
this is more relationship to you
it doesn't mean it's bad but it just
says summer tablescape
decorate with me it's not actually
it's not how to do a particular thing
it's not how to use a particular
searchable product so it's
kind of it's a weak topic
but on top of that when it is
transformation we're going to take
people from
from their table or their dining room is
terrible
and it's going to be awesome after the
ultimate hook
is how hgtv
does home makeover things there there's
a panning shot of the the
room and it looks awful and then it goes
bring and then it shows the completed
project
and in the beginning i go oh shoot like
i want to stick around for this whole
show to see how they got there so i can
learn about the transformation
so even from like a storytelling
perspective i have 10 seconds
of an intro i have you
introducing yourself and saying you're
gonna decorate
i don't really know where i'm going you
know tension hasn't been set up conflict
hasn't been set up
um and by conflict this this is like
good storytelling
even though we're just making youtube
videos we want them to be like mini
movement uh
movies and so the best movies have
uh that where they go as they go in hgtv
the room is a disaster
it gets here but then they show you some
previews of what's coming up in the
episode
and then they're like oh shoot we broke
the countertop oh there's water
everywhere or there
and we're not always going to do that
but does that that's what makes us want
to stick around
tension conflict a story arc a vision of
the destination
and then embracing the process to get to
get there
and we can include those elements even
in just a home decor video
and so that's any feedback on that so
far in regards i realized i just
pictured
this video so you suggest that i should
show
the finished picture first and then go
into showing them how i set it up
100 and a lot that's
uh the it's just kind of the way our
brains work we want to know
where we're going to end up and so in
beauty channels
they show the completed look and then we
take it back to
no makeup on and then we're like okay
let's take it there and they might show
them side by side
um and and that is then teasing
and i would really recommend at least
check out the podcast with brendan kane
because he breaks down
hook point and um or the audiobook or
the book hook point because
hooks are the thumbnail the title that's
the big idea it starts before the video
even starts and then it's the beginning
of the video
the content needs to continue to be good
but if we don't get them there
this is why we're going to get our
hockey stick of average view duration
because and and we've already lost at
that point like if it's
it's never going to be a high-performing
video if it doesn't
um you know necessarily grab our
attention early on
so with that let me check out this one
to see
a couple things we can learn from one of
your better videos i think the first
thing
that i think this video is doing better
is because
yeah and it's a result if i really want
to make some clay pop people
then i'm hanging out with you that's
very niche very specific and you got 12
000 views
that's a topic decision that is in my
opinion 150 times stronger than just
decorate with me this is what my table
is like
it's fine too but like if if you by the
way if you
kept doing clay pot people level videos
that just means that your baseline would
be every video you do
gets 10 12 000 views at least and maybe
higher than that
that's a topic decision because clearly
you're capable of making the video
but it's pivoting the strategy and
making your video choice
uh the topics are actually does that
make sense yeah
it does it does because at first i was
doing the hook
and then the intro and then i would go
into the video
but i was noticing uh that people were
skipping
past all of that and just going into the
video so that's why i took off the hook
off the front
well what i would say too though is that
the hook
should not need to be skipped it should
be so
brief concise um that it
uh that people just go okay this is
what's coming up like there's enough
happening in the beginning of the video
and by the way i mean if i you're here
i took that one down because it was too
long i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure
and and it also to me feels all over the
place
home decor and thrifty makes sense
makeup okay
life like life is is pretty broad
and i think you've got clarity since
then and i realize yeah
yeah great and nevertheless this video
still got 12 000 views
yeah hi everyone this is stephanie of
creative miss me
and today i'm coming to you with a diy
project now you probably don't want me
to talk because
you've grown since then but you don't
need
hi everyone it's stephanie uh right now
you don't necessarily need and i'm
getting ready to paint so i'm gonna show
you the start
so we got right into it there that
wasn't too bad it wasn't it wasn't super
long
but my thing is get right into it and i
and i like this but what i would have
loved to see too and again this video
still did good so if you
if you talk about the right topic with
some good content it could be forgiving
you got 12 000 views
but how to make it even better would
have been to show me what's the final
result
if you said while you were telling me
hey stephanie here and i'm so excited
because i'm going to show you how to
make this
okay that's the hook okay so i'm so
pumped you're here because
i'm gonna actually be breaking down how
to do and you show the result like okay
i want to hang around for that
and so um is that helpful like
those are a few tweaks i think refining
your
and then choosing topics that
are going to lead to the views that you
want to get
it matters and again it's youtube
meaning
it's your tube you can do whatever you
want i can do whatever i want
but we're not entitled to get views from
that necessarily so if we
want to trigger the algorithm get views
this is why topic research or
understanding our audience or making
smart videos
really is helpful and they may not get
12 000 views but i think
on the other side of this information
and you applying it you'll start hitting
1 000
2 500 more consistently and then you'll
start hitting
some 15 000 won some 25 000 ones does
that make sense
yes i need to get more on the camera too
because i kind of
avoid the camera yes
and i know i do i avoid the camera a lot
i i mean and that's i think getting on
camera is great but i think also getting
people the result
and having the voice over and showing
your hands and showing what you're
building that's entirely up to you
some of the biggest channels are kind of
like tasty where there's no one on
camera it's the hands
cooking the food showing the final
result and just being quick and getting
to that end
product now i want to use this time uh
together
to make a point now stephanie i don't
want you to feel
well i'm about to show you a video from
nolan on think media now nolan's been
video for like 12 years you know we have
a lot of nice gear we have all of those
things
so i'm not suggesting that anybody
watching this has to come close to
those types of details about this what i
want you to see
is how he does the hook
principally like the principles of it
and so
let's check out the first few seconds of
this video
as a coffee with kennel community and
see what we can learn
you're trying to get to a thousand
subscribers and four thousand watch
hours so the question is should you be
posting
longer videos or should you be posting
shorter videos i'm going to show you
some real
okay so i mean the first thing
a it was b-roll all at the beginning and
a voiceover
and he didn't say hey nolan here or
anything like that
he started straight with the value with
some
uh you know open-ended questions um
a very specific pain point people have
and
he also um is using just b-roll that we
get from like stock footage websites
you know like uh wherever i'm trying to
think of that one video blog
i use
and you don't have to use those but i
would suggest your
b-roll is the final product it is the
final part people you know what i mean
but it's just
it's it's like fast it's like an opening
to reality tv show
you're trying to get to a thousand
subscribers and four thousand watch
hours so the question is should you be
posting
longer videos or should you be posting
shorter videos i'm gonna show you some
real examples that we have on this
channel one
is a long video that did really well and
then one is a short video that did
really well for us
i'm going to share why i think the long
video and the short video both did well
for us and which ones
you should be doing you got to just so
completely tease everything up teases us
we're gonna see analytics we're gonna
see a lot of different you know cool
things
and we're at 23 seconds in the whole
video
and just comparing to your latest video
i'm i'm saying get to the point cut to
the chase get there fast
you know we played that 10 second opener
there was some stuff about you
some stuff about whatever we're at like
43 seconds and i didn't really know
where we were going
and and so i think that
some pivots to those things are going to
make a world of difference in the
content creation
let's check out the bumper on think
media how long the bumper or it's also
known as the logo sting
is okay you got to just press record hey
guys my name it's one second long
so our think media logos saying you
gotta just press record you should be
doing
you gotta just press record hey guys my
name is nolan
okay we don't have to i'm not
suggesting and there's plenty of
channels couple second
intro they don't put like we want to
become dogmatic
about these principles however
we have to adapt them to our niche and
our industry
if we want to really trigger growth can
you still have a seven or ten second
intro
on a cooking video or a decor video sure
and videos still succeed
you know if you say your name in the
beginning this like those
like there's the nuances it's not
getting too stuck in that but the
formula of
cutting to the chase teasing what's
coming up
right act you know letting the viewer
know what's coming up is something that
they they want to see
and getting that all done in a
relatively short amount of time
and lastly hey guys my name is normal
from think media now we had a
so his introduction is two seconds my
name is nolan
think media now and he's into it we got
the social media comment come in from
ella browning and she asked in response
to a specific question from the
community that's a great way like what
questions what is your audience and you
could also use your community tab
to do with some surveys on your next
video but yeah i've started doing that
yeah i started doing the poll on the
community tab with a pick a color
and i do a paper scape that month on
that color
awesome okay so that's awesome and maybe
give them though
specifically try this come up with like
four of your best video idea topics
should i do how to make x
how to fix a wardrobe how to hide
damage on a wall like whatever four
topics you want
okay put four topics on there and then
see which one they vote on
and here's what i'm saying all four are
good you're pumped about all four
then let the your community have vote
and then go make that video next
um and so anyways as we land the plane
on that and i hope this has been
valuable
you know now nolan it's 32 seconds in
the video i feel like i've got
a good tea up of everything that's
happening etc
but we're right into the content at 32
seconds he's introduced himself
one second bumper he showed me some
stuff frame the conversation
you know um that's definitely hook point
principles
and uh any any takeaways has this been
helpful stephanie
very helpful i have ideas just
clicking now very amazing amazing i
appreciate you so much
and if if you want to look up uh and
have something to do next check out this
video
how to stand on youtube with hook points
it's 32 minutes long
you could type in think media podcast
brendan kane his name's brendan kane
and uh this interview is is really the
overview i highly recommend the book
but of course the fastest path is to
maybe just check out
this interview to start and uh have you
heard about our podcast
uh stephanie is this the first time or
have you listened to that
i've listened to a few uh do you listen
to him here on youtube or do you listen
to him on spotify or apple or where
youtube okay well awesome uh
stephanie did you hear this one no
okay well this is this is the one to
check out next you're gonna love it um
how to stand out on youtube with hook
points so definitely check out that
video and stephanie i hope you have
um an amazing day thank you so much
appreciate you um
coffee with candle crew smash the like
button
uh if you've been getting value today uh
grateful that you're here today's
episode is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
free one hour on demand youtube web
class
check that out what is your biggest aha
moment so far from today
from some of the stuff we've been
talking to about with stephanie or
denise
um did you get any insights over how
nolan
opened up uh his uh videos
you know um there is a feature inside of
your youtube analytics
and uh if you go to audience and then
after you've clicked on audience you go
to engagement
it's not funny uh there's this feature
called key moments for audience
retention
and it says still watching at 30 seconds
you're going to want to study
shows our last 10 videos how aggressive
the drop-off
of even can we hold people's attention
for the for the
first 30 seconds so we showed you
the first 30 seconds in nolan's video
how quick it was how brief it was
and again you don't have to
you know have the editing skills of
nolan or even be subscribed to a b-roll
site that's not the important principle
important principle the important
principle is
you gotta you can't waste people's time
you gotta get to the point
tease what's coming up if you're doing a
tutorial show them the end result
they're gonna get
trim the fluff don't tell your life
story you know
hey sean here and i'm so excited like
you can introduce yourself
um and you also could consider moving
the pleasantries to the end of the video
because you know how people's journeys
start on youtube they're actually
probably not looking for a new friend
they're probably not looking for a new
youtube channel to subscribe
for they're looking to start with value
they may become a new friend they may
become a super fan
but what if you made a seven minute
video and you just got straight to the
point and you delivered all the value
and you delivered all that value for the
first five minutes
and then when the people who weren't
gonna hang around with you anyways
go cool thanks thanks for helping me get
my thanks you know table decorated for
thanksgiving just bail
at five minutes you just go and hey by
the way if we're just meeting my name's
sean
you know my mission is to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living on youtube and
if you want to subscribe we put out free
content and we do free trainings and
got a coffee with candle show and maybe
some people
during the first five minutes resonated
with you well they'll stick around
some will drop off they were never going
to stick around anyways
so you can even put your introduction in
pleasantries
towards the end of the video don't make
that too long
and that's how little by little little
by little you will
attract super fans
because the majority of people who visit
your channel aren't going to stick
around but some will
and and there's no need to necessarily
bother the person who's looking at your
content for a utility
early on with too much info be brief be
bright
be fun be done on to the next video
hey we're gonna do a lightning round
with uh ray just uh
as we land the plane today on this two
hour stream of
coffee with cannell content coconut
water content
with kennel ray my man hey where are you
watching from and uh what's your
question
right outside washington d.c awesome ray
how can i help
um a new niche
i'm unsure about those if um you should
wait and see how it grows
if it grows or get on the ground floor
what's the niche it is uh flying cars
flying humans you've probably seen some
of the crazy youtubers doing it already
yeah like the people writing drones and
stuff right riding drones you got it
okay um you're gonna start a new channel
correct you already have a channel yes
no content
okay so you can go any direction you
want correct
all right well here's here's the move
ray um what you're going to want to do
is um i don't think
you need to brand a channel that
specifically
and here's what i mean there's all
like there's just so much debate and
everyone's got an opinion niche down
don't niche down the truth is
you need to be focused focus is power
like
uh starbucks started in like 1971 in
seattle
and they um grew
massive i came from the pacific
northwest they had
so slow growth at the start by 2003 they
were crushing
but then they started music and movies
anybody remember that
they started literally their own music
label they opened up a studio in l.a
and they even won grammys from their
music but what happened was
they um they stopped focusing on the
main thing
and their service went down their
baristas went down
their promise to their audience was
coffee and they stopped delivering on
the coffee
and their stock price dropped a couple
years later they were
in real trouble so they closed
their movie division and their music
division and why and some people are
probably like starbucks did music yeah
it's
this is the shiny object that can hit us
as creators where we
are like let's do this thing or that
thing and ray i'm bringing this
somewhere in regards to your question
yeah uh so what they did was they
canceled the distraction
they got focused and they focused on
being the best at coffee
ever um they also focused on you know
food in their
uh little refrigerated area and
breakfast pastries and they just double
down on service on creating a third
place
their stock over the next couple years
they did incredibly well now it's over
350 000 employees i think over
40 billion net worth for the starbucks
company global
and so power focus when it comes to
youtube
i think you actually just want you want
to have niche
videos but you could have a broader
niche
channel so here's what i mean like
the mistake if you've niched too far i
think is if you make a flying car's
channel
it's possible that that does well but
it's it's
super niche down it's a little more
risky but have you ever heard of the
magazine the verge
or the online blog the verb so think
about the verge
what's their niche
okay what is your thought from your
opinion
i've read their articles and they're
very good i just can't remember because
i read so much
okay so the verge is kind of like a
junkie it's kind of like
tech uh gadgets
yeah you're right they'd cover flying
cars they'd cover
ces consumer electronics show they'd
cover
new data about how much money youtube
earned it's kind of
but the verge has a niche and this is
where people are like don't niche down
well no the verge has a brand has focus
has a they also have a team to produce a
lot of content underneath that umbrella
but i've never seen them post 52
summer inspired outfits for men
i've never seen them aspire you know
best cocktail recipes i've never
seen them how to do table decor i've
seen them cover tesla
even though they don't really cover cars
because it's more tech
and progress you know what i mean they
cover cars but under the technology
banner and those who love the verge
understand what they're getting from it
and why they subscribed
all right so the channel i want you to
start ray
is i want you to just start a brand or a
name
or a channel that's essentially like the
verge
but the niching down is your first
50 100 200
500 videos that are all about flying
cars and flying humans
what can happen is a year from now
you're just crushing and even though
your channel is called the smurge
you know like whatever the name is
people are like oh yeah that's the
flying car channel
or if flying cars don't really take off
you put out 50 videos
and they do okay but you also can pivot
because i think the idea of where you
could
swim inside of the brand the verge like
for you whatever that is
and it you know so that the your channel
might be car
called like smart tech or future
tech or you know future flight
or whatever and you know flight could be
abstract or literal in terms of flying
cars and flying humans
then build the brand set the channel up
and
and maybe your first 250 videos only
talk about flying cars that's great
that's the power of making niche videos
under a channel
that doesn't constrain you too much
because you got so specific in the
channel name and what you were thinking
does that make sense right
yes it does cool that's what i do
awesome
i recommend a lot of people coming to
stu your channel and reach out to you
a lot of wannabe influencers i tell them
to go right to you well i appreciate it
ray and thank you so much
i hope things the weather looks
beautiful in washington dc right now
very nice it's a pool day oh come on i
wish i
it's too hot to be at the pool even here
the pool is a hot tub in vegas it's like
108 but uh
hey i appreciate you and thanks so much
for coming on i appreciate your
your staff too just as much take care
all right take care
coffee with canal
wider niche channel specific niche
videos it's so funny
people say you know we just released a
video why having a niche is a bad idea
you should niche down you know what i
think the bigger conversation as we land
the plane is
it's you need to focus you need to focus
message of the day focus follow one
course until successful focus
might mean you experiment within a
particular area but if you lack focus
like the chinese proverbs proverb
states if you try and chase two rabbits
you'll end up catching neither that's a
focus
thing oh but what about the exception of
this channel just
be focused just stop going in 48
directions
get really focused and you'll get better
results if you're just joining i feel
like this whole episode was pretty
valuable that is two hours worth of
content but the conversation
with stephanie the conversation with ray
conversation with denise
conversation with zach a lot of good
conversations of course the youtube
domination frameworks up front
in this video for like the first 30
minutes if you got value today smash
light
if you got an aha moment not just
because i want engagement but
admittedly i would love some engagement
i do think it's powerful when you type
out
your aha moment because it's kind of
like the unlock it's vocalizing or
typing and putting it
in the comments what's your takeaway
more important to me is what are you
going to take action on
what was like an unlock that's going to
lead to action
because we're not just dabbling we're
dominating right
and so let me know what stood out to you
today i really appreciate you
hit the like button if you got value and
if you really want to take a next step
uh and go a little bit deeper on getting
results on youtube making money
and some of the best strategies for
getting views right now
thinkmasterclass.com
is um in the description as well as you
can just type in
that url my name is sean cannell
the show is coffee with kennel and i
cannot wait to see you on the next
episode until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it
and we will talk soon peace